I wasn't expecting you uh change of plan
my dear ADA
change of plan is everything okay
Leopold you look sad
yeah yeah you know everything's fine
just um bit overwhelmed with what Castle
I'm sorry to hear that
but too observant I have to take a look
at that in the next software patch it's
almost as if she knew I felt guilty no
don't be silly feds it I can't
differentiate I know what you're doing
doctor you came here to end my life well
that's not true a doe he simply wanted
to make it few upgrades that's all the
bloody hell I made a few upgrades of my
own
you
hey youtubers agents of shield is coming
back next week there's a whole bunch of
stuff that's going on they change is
going on with Doctor Strange in the
movies so let's break it down there is a
new Hulkbuster giveaway that's starting
now for agents of shield videos all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Marvel related comment on
this video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so that you don't miss
anything so it seems like [ __ ] just got
real she's turning into Ultron but
really what's going on here you know
let's do like top 10 number 10
they are passing the torch from Ghost
Rider to life model decoys for like the
story arc the back half of the season if
you're behind the last couple of
episodes they've slowly been ramping up
ADA's plot like she's slowly becoming a
bigger and bigger thing remember at the
beginning of the season they just teased
her like oh my god there's a life model
decoy and she's hilariously
inappropriate she just says really
awkward things and it's funny so number
nine the Darkhold plot became a big
thing with the Ghost Rider character
this mystery book that was a bit of a
MacGuffin it was really dangerous people
read from it went crazy the human mind
couldn't handle it so number eight they
had ada read it because her computer
brain which is capable of processing so
much more information so the joke about
this is when they were realizing that a
human mind couldn't handle the dark hold
agent may is the one who insists that
ADA read it so that they can find a way
to defeat Eli Morrow dr. Radcliffe
shaking his head no no no so number
seven the big reveal is that May is a
life model decoy she totally could have
read the book herself but even though
ADA seems like she's gained this crazy
power from reading the dark Holt you
know number seven she actually seems
like she swapped in life model decoy may
a long time ago so if you remember way
back to Episode four that was the last
time we can confirm we saw human may
being treated by ADA because at the end
of the last episode they did the big
reveal where she was keeping me locked
up in that little life model decoy
closet in the fake may was with Coulson
saying I'm right where I need to be like
it's meant to be this really touching
moment but you the scary music in the
background like oh my god what's there
plan is this going to be like a bunch of
Cylon style Ultron replicants but
whatever this has to do with the
Darkhold
it was all set in motion before ADA read
the Darkhold
so she had been planning this this whole
time so number six the Darkhold brain we
don't actually know if ADA has installed
that yet but basically what it seems
like it is is it something to free
herself from outside control like if
you've ever heard of the idea of an
air-gapped computer it's a computer
that's never been connected to the
Internet so it's like a self-contained
system it seems like that was the reason
that a DES built that special brain for
herself but it might also do some really
special stuff too because it's basically
made of dark matter
like she built the Gateway that allowed
Coulson and Fitz to come back from the
Dark Dimension they've been really
careful about what they call that other
place - it's basically hell as
ghostwriter explains it like the spirit
of vengeance inside Ghost Rider tells
them I am NOT going back there so
wherever it is whatever they're going to
call it it really is Marvel's version of
Hell so we're getting into prime
Mephisto stuff that kind of bleeds into
Doctor Strange Dormammu Dark Dimension
stuff - because number five creating
something from nothing that was Eli
Morrow's big thing like look I can
create matter out of nothing and fits in
like pretty much every other scientist
on the TV show is like that's [ __ ]
you can't create something out of
nothing that energy has to come from
somewhere so if you remember the zealots
from Doctor Strange they drew energy
from other dimensions to power their
spells in when they drew from the Dark
Dimension it was like extra powerful
energy so number four the follow-up
question what about ghost writer in Eli
Morrow at the end of the season
like blaze of glory style Ghost Rider
goes out like a champ and is basically
trying to take Eli Morrow back to hell
take him back to this other dimension
where all this mystery energy is coming
from so technically it is another
dimension but we can just call it hell
for all intents and purposes just
because that's what the spirit of
vengeance in psycho strider was calling
it so when they say that the show is
moving its focus to life model decoys
that doesn't mean that Ghost Rider is
never coming back that just means that
he's trapped in hell right now
he will definitely come back
by the end of the season in some big
moment but the question is is will we
actually get to see what's going on in
hell because you know going over to like
the Thor comics there was a period of
time where Thor was trapped in the
Asgardian version of Hell hgl Hell at
the mercy of hella but as you can
imagine being at the mercy of the devil
it's just like endless torture both
psychological and physical killing you
every day than bringing you back to life
so that she can torture you and kill you
again over and over and over they
actually did that on Westworld i've died
millions of times i'm great at it
so there just seems like there's a lot
of like AI stuff going on in pop culture
right now you have AI robots gone crazy
on West world now you have AI robots on
agents of shield gone crazy
but number three don't forget the other
big storyline is the new mystery inhuman
that Jeffrey mace the Patriot was making
this deal behind the scenes to try and
take care of so what we know is that the
government official that has been
blackmailing Jeffrey mace knows who this
person is and it seems like a fairly
high-ranking or a wealthy person a
person of importance that they're trying
to hide the identity of and even though
they've kind of dropped the Inhumans
storyline on agents of shield the big
runner was rights for Inhumans like we
deserve all of the same treatment as
regular people so they're like this
underclass of citizens right now in the
world so I'm guessing that storyline is
where it's going to loop back around and
grab this new mystery inhuman because
Jeffrey maze-like went public on TV and
said I'm an inhuman they put me in
charge of shield because I'm trustworthy
his big deal is trust even though he's
been very not trustworthy this season so
far but just remember that even though
it doesn't seem like it's a big deal
there will be more inhuman stuff
happening later via this new mystery
inhuman so number two Jeffrey mace the
Patriot he's an inhuman you know
strength on par with Captain America as
if you were to have the Super Soldier
Serum the big wink here is that way back
in the classic Captain America comics
the Patriot wielded the mantle of
Captain America and the shield for a
period of time so everyone's asking like
well you get to wield this shield so
Jason O'Mara the voice of Batman the guy
who's playing Jeffrey mace on the TV
show I love the Batman in
director of shield right now like at the
end of Civil War
Captain America leaves the shield behind
so nobody is wielding the shield right
now
so if patriot was such a big character
they chose him for a reason on the TV
show and turned him into an inhuman it's
like a slight change from the comics the
Patriot is not an inhuman in the comics
they just want him to seem like a
Captain America type character so I
think that that means that he will
eventually wield Captain America's
shield whether or not it's like the
energy shield that Coulson has or the
actual physical Captain America shield
but the number one big thing though is
in actually finding out what is the
intelligence behind this other dimension
so everybody's wondering does that mean
that Mephisto is eventually going to
come on the TV show because it gets
really confusing when you talk about who
has the TV rights who has the movie
rights for different characters
technically Mephisto appeared for the
first time during a Silver Surfer comic
that's a Fox character but that's the
movies not the TV shows Marvel actually
still has the rights for x-men on TV
which is a really weird situation so let
me know in the comments what are you
most hype about for the back half of
agents of shield life model decoys or
really finding who's controlling this
other Dark Dimension that the Ghost
Rider spirit of vengeance is so afraid
of but just a reminder agents of shield
is back next week so I will do an
episode video but what's going to happen
is is at the end of the month when all
the DC shows come back there's going to
be a log jam of videos because legends
of tomorrow is moving to Tuesday nights
so I've got like a whole bunch of videos
that I'll have to try and do within like
a really small span of time so some of
it is going to have to get pushed a
little bit to like Thursdays so you guys
will like this what I'm going to do
because I've been doing the spider-man
giveaway is I'm actually going to do a
Hulkbuster giveaway for agents of shield
just for the agents of shield videos so
be sure to look out for that when I post
it next Tuesday but I'll go ahead and
start it now so I'll announce the winner
in that first agents of shield video but
up next tonight I got some new flash
season 3 postings so that should be up
in a little while where you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
learn all about the Doctor Strange
team-up and Thor Ragnarok and you can
click here to learn about all the crazy
stuff that's coming up
thank you so much for watching everybody
what's that Bob I'll see you guys
tonight